I'm Norman beer I am the director of the
open learning initiative and the
executive director of the Simon
initiative me when we talk about the
open learning initiative is both a
pioneering movement and open education
but also it is distinctly CMU it's
something I don't could have happened
any more but Carnegie Mellon so so yeah
so you got the chance to try this out at
in 110 right what's a little whiny about
having to take it because I heard all
these you know frightening stories so I
put off til taking it till my senior
year even though like I had known this
was the next vacation since my freshman
year and so then I was like I was
talking my advisor about it and she was
like you know what do it over the summer
if you're this nervous because then you
can just pour all your focus into 110 um
and honestly like the experience I'm I
now understand why to requirement for
psychology majors I kind of think it
should be requirement for everyone who
goes to CMU just because at least a lot
of times especially in the west coast
when I tell people I go to CMU every
single person's like oh you're an
engineer oh your computer science you
know person okay actually I'm saying
psychology but you're right you're one
of our string yeah I was like you're
right a lot of my peers are so I think
it's really good because I don't know
like the CMU label kind of comes with
this technical idea in this technical
background so now I feel like I've
participated even a super small part of
it like makes me feel like I deserve the
title a little more no I think that's
sad but one of the things was trying to
get out into the class was that notion
that you know you really are
participating and one of the men with a
lot of great traditions here but i think
that the work we've done in CS is just
you know it's this enormous river and
maybe you're just dipping your foot into
it but you're a part of it now and
that's pretty exciting I mean obviously
the course at least the way that we were
doing it in the summer and I think them
in the way it's being introduced now in
the in the in the phone spring semesters
is able to take advantage of a lot of
the work coming out of the sign
initiative which includes vol I courses
and so I'm curious how did that compare
to some of the other classes you've
taken of courses that didn't have the
ability to use some of the EdTech pieces
oh I would say it's kind of tough like
see you are tired during lecture or
something like that or for some reason
you miss a lecture and lecture is really
rich but there's not really a way to get
like those notes
and I feel like oli has like a backup if
something like that happen it's not like
you should miss lecture or anything but
in the case that you do or that
something doesn't work out you're able
to go to the whole I modules and you're
able to like kind of get caught up or
like at least get a buffer for what
you'd missed and I like that
accessibility to have that great oh I
was really helpful because I could do it
before class then I felt like I kind of
knew what I was getting into in class
and then if I ever was kind of confused
from the in-class portion I knew that
like it wasn't the end I'll be loved
that moment like I had to learn and
understand in that moment like I had
time and structured time in which I
could learn it by myself or with the
guide of the ol I modules okay and did
you feel like the online materials in
the supporting tech blended fairly well
with the with the diction alas time did
yeah did we get those synced up fairly
well yeah I think so i think um the i
always loved at the end the question
that was like what do you want your
instructor to spend more time one
because at least the way you didn't you
really talked about that and you really
use that and that was it kind of made
you feel like you're learning experience
was like being valued and that like you
weren't necessarily expected to 100%
understand everything that had happened
during the oh I module or during class
yeah and I think if that's used properly
it can be pretty nice because I've just
been thinking about this semester people
do not like asking questions in lecture
at CMU because everybody's afraid that
you're there asking the dumb question
when in reality there has to be at least
one other person in the lecture hall
that feels the same way so even though
it would be nice to have that problem be
fixed it's nice because this gives an
opportunity where you don't just like
stay silent and fear of being judged
necessarily you can just type in like
hey like this is me to you as my
professor could you please spend some
more time on this yeah we talked a lot
about the availability of the technology
to eliminate the back row or to bring
the back row students forward
metaphorically and I think that that's a
piece of it right i mean it's but it's
also i think normalizing that piece of
learning that requires you to
acknowledge hey i don't know exactly
what's happening here i need to ask
questions and so it gives you a vehicle
for doing that
and it ties it a little more directly to
what you've just learned right so
there's that close relationship to I've
just had this practice things unclear I
can get that information out and then
hopefully benefit from faculty yeah I
think particularly the activity portion
when you're not graded on but there's
the checkpoint at the end which is
obviously graded and important feedback
for the instructor but the the portion
that you know likes it goes you know
appears green if you've gotten a write
or read if you've gotten it wrong but
that you know you can kind of try it
again makes it a lot less intimidating
because if it's immediately graded then
there's you're still kind of stressed
out by the whole experience because you
know like this is a one-shot moment but
the thief the feedback I think in
particular is really helpful because
most other feedback you get in a
classroom is graded feedback just
because that's the nature of school but
it kind of offers a unique opportunity
for non-graded feedback for the
activities was there anything any
specific pieces of it that really stood
out as you know what were some of the
best ones tell me the worst ones to what
really worked for you I think for me the
ones where you could actually code in
Python in the in the module itself and
it would give you feedback I really
appreciate it because the whole idea of
coding even literally just sending
enough on my computer was intimidating
to me so the fact that you could do it
just like in the web browser and in the
module so the only thing you needed to
focus on with actually whether your code
was working or not was really helpful to
me I think one of the other things
that's important about about the way
that the larger Simon initiative worse
is this ability to take some of the data
that's coming from your experiences with
these materials and feed it back into
the research space and is sort of
curious as to how that felt to you I
mean work through the consent form I
talked a little bit about this does that
change the experience at all is it does
it feel important to you yeah it's kind
of cool to be on the front line or at
least the liq a long line of progress
for a new initiative in general just
like I don't really think like you can
mention the consent form doesn't really
bother me to think that like the way
answer things like how I do in the class
is being like used in research I mean
like I said when I whenever I didn't
pass 112 it kind of just had to be
honest with people and I think honesty
is important and it's important for
learning as well so no big deal
whatsoever from
you like if I have some trouble in one
area like that's okay is going to help
students down the road notion that
what's driving this research is students
participating in the work which is being
done by a student really yeah it creates
pretty exciting cycle it says that the
knowledge that's being that that's being
created here is actually being
co-created and the students are an
essential part of this right it changes
what a university community looks like
so I think that's pretty neat